so welcome everyone so we probably know
the title of the talk so just a little
context about me I work mostly as a
developer in several industries I can
say the last one was estimate which is
Internet of Things startup which
specializes in location indoors so we
they use their own devices called
beacons to position people indoors and
the previous companies were about
healthcare like high matter which
detects early signs of autism in
children and some finance our size
directed startups so the beginning small
disclaimer especially after the gtp are
to the torque title and after is to
really talk so it's not fully it's not
official legal advice for our companies
it's more about best practices for
developers who actually do their work
and if you if you need specific answers
for your company problems I think from
my experience and experience from my
colleagues from from the industry that
you should you probably already have
some friend who's legal person or a
lawyer and they probably know the
details of the GTR with regulation and
another thing that maybe you wonder is
we had GDP our talk yesterday which was
great
so why another one isn't
the application but now this this one is
more low-level and more about how those
things that happened or we were
regulated at the top translate to your
daily workflow and how you can apply
best practices so the amount of their
work you need to do to achieve full
compliance is minimized so in computer
science everything is about of the magaz
asian so here we optimize optimize about
us developers or data scientists so at
the beginning short why developers
should care about GDP are because all
those big fines and restrictions are
about companies so why should I even
care about that and I think that it's
more about personal responsibility about
how do you feel about your work if it's
if the code you you you produce and ship
is like ethically okay and the another
reason is more practical at some point
your boss can give you the task okay we
need to be compliant to operate continue
our operations so you actually can be in
situation where you are forced to to do
those things so it's better to be to be
prepared and sometimes I've heard when
all that how all that hype about GDP are
started in last month and all that it
was shown in the media and in the press
that it's a big thing but the regulation
was finalized two years ago so we all
have time
but still sometimes I heard like excuses
why not to change anything for better
and the first was not that's not my
problem as a developer I will wait till
the till the bus or the manager gives me
the task to change some things but as I
said if you start early you have less
work to do later another excuse and like
work around which sometimes may work but
in most cases I think it's not good idea
to reject
European Union residence as clients so
you technically don't need to comply
with regulation but actually finding
who's the you European Union resident
from young clients is additional big
task and it's not so easy to figure out
who should be treated as a European
citizen who not and it's additional big
amount of work so maybe it's better to
stay with yourself bags but just do the
things better another is that we should
postpone making changes until we are
notified that we are not compliant and
we we will be first legally to to make
some changes and again I think that it's
better to not to wait but to change
things step by step to not be overflown
with the amount of work that needs to be
done and some markets require additional
curve so if you work for example for
health care you probably are already
familiar with the standards
and if you want to operate on for
example German or American market you
need to comply with the standards and
those standards are sometimes even more
restrict than GDP are so it's so it's
actually legally required if you do want
to do business for health care with for
example with the clinics to to operate
on a high level of transparency and
security and privacy and another tricky
market is IOT so an IOT maybe it's not
so regulated as a health care but it
provides you with such big amount of
data about the users that you actually
have a choice to if you want to do
something like more transparent with
that or if you want to use all the data
and maybe build the products that are
not so well communicated to users and
actually uses the data that shouldn't be
be used for example about people
location so until I go further I wanted
to just introduce you four key terms
used when we talk about GDP our East
it's that our subject so it's actually
every one of us as a user because we
produce the data in all the systems we
we use and the products so actually
everything we do as a developers may
affect our sole personal data that was
kind of surprised for me that
the beginning when I was reading about
gdpr I was thinking that personal data
is only about health care records or
some salary details but it may be things
about behavior at work some preferences
when you browse the internet so actually
it's way more broad term then you can
think at the beginning so it's worth to
think twice about storing something
because you might think okay but who
cares if I track the users which product
protects you user roles in my system
because that's not personal data but it
actually may may be in the definition
the data controller is can be companion
or institution that actually owns the
the data at the end stores the
information or or use uses the this
personal data to build products or
services for end users and the the
second like institutional or company
that may work with the data is data
processor some sometimes if you for
example use use some mailing services or
use external databases or some platform
as a service so those companies became
data processors so they process the data
for the data controller and the two most
important scenarios we need to consider
when we think about protection of
privacy is profiling
so you probably know the term it's about
connecting the specific person the data
subject with with some analytics or
information about him and some may might
be inputted the system by the user but
some may might be calculated with for
example machine learning to for example
calculate the likelihood of conversion
in some size system or a likelihood of
disease in healthcare system so most of
our industry machine learning models
provide the users and enhance them with
additional metadata and sometimes we use
those results to build automated
decision-making things like
recommendation system or some ranking
system and it may use profiling but it
doesn't have to and the second thing I
think it's even more important to to
comply and I will cover the topic a
little bit later ok so if I need to say
what like general rule to follow in
order to to minimize the work of needed
to be done to comply is it's about
constant and transparency so the first
one it's about asking the user if he
actually wants to allow the company to
process the data they want and you will
probably receive a lot of emails about
giving constant for newsletters and
things like this so you you know the
idea
but I think that the constant should
always go with transparency so if you
ask the user above some rights or about
some some data you should be transparent
and clear about what will actually
happen or what you want to achieve and
not hide the true true goal behind some
like a fuzzy or complicated legal
language so let's jump into best
practices so the the first one is
anonymization and it's all about that if
you remove the the user from the data
and you'll you are sure that it's not
possible to identify the information
about gathered information with the user
they belong you may may use it it's in
detail in details it's it's a little bit
more complicated but as general rule if
you see that it's not necessary to
connect the data points with the
specific person you can remove that
connection as soon as possible maybe in
the mobile app or on the data collection
steps and or add some middleware that
ensures that some specific connection
between data points or some specific
data it's actually not collected or not
connected so it's as we yesterday heard
sometimes it's even wise to just remove
the data you don't need and you know
that you will not use to not think later
okay how secure we should I store some
personal information that actually my
business don't need so if it's less less
unused or unimportant data there is less
stress about how to process and store it
securely later and we go to
documentation I know that probably most
of you don't like writing the
documentation I personally had the same
experience but at some point I
discovered that actually it's great for
communication between the team members
of of projects and it helps not only to
save for the future how the things were
developed but it helps with things like
introducing new team members to the
project and in for example in healthcare
you actually are obligated to document
most part of the of the process so it's
not something that you can hide from so
it's better to do it smart so what
should you document if you are doing
some machine learning project so first
thing is data sets so if you collect
data for training validation or or
testing it's wise to collect as much
meta data about this collection process
as possible and usually in some
predefined format so it's good if you
have a team it's good to meet at the
beginning of the project and build some
guidelines about documenting the the
data sets and the rest part of the
system
so it's not so it's consistent across
there and other iterations and you can
compare datasets from different
different phrases of the of the project
and it's important if you collect for
example data from the users to to also
be sure that you you respect the privacy
and if I said that you should collect as
much metadata as possible but think use
common sense and I think what what may
be treated as a personal data
another one is documentation of models
and parameters so according to GPR
sentence it may happened situation where
you need to explain the user how some
decision was made and the first thing to
start with is to actually knew which
model was used with with parameters and
without writing documentation on each
step or through the whole project it may
be really really hard some sometimes the
team members of of the team who who
build it are no longer in the company or
in the project or just forgot so it's
wise to to have track of the details of
the models we use not only in the
machine learning models but the whole
pipeline so if you move data from data
store to machine learning server or
service and then move the results to
another database it's important to
document how that flow and so you by
building the
documentation of data pipeline you
actually see another important thing is
it's where the data grows and which
external services uses I'll help you
process the data because they also need
to comply so you need to be sure that if
you for example at the end use some
mailing service to send the results or
some information to users to you you
will when making that documentation you
will see that okay now it's time to
check if this mailing service is GD /
compliant yeah so external services
mostly behave as data controllers and
it's it's important to choose the the
ones who already comply I think that the
most external third-party services used
GTRs now as a marketing tools so they
used to they like to tell you okay we
are we are safe secure and GD /
compliant so it's not so hard to to be
sure and another thing is data paper
pipelines so after we have everything
document documented and if the user
wants to know what
why decision for example about credit
score or some health diagnosis how how
it happened sometimes and they can say
okay but I refuse I don't no longer give
you consent to to use my data or I want
to modify some parts of information you
have about me or I I want to modify
everything so documentation is not
something that will make it it will make
easier to know what should be
changed but if if you don't have well
automated data pipelines and processes
it this situation can be really hard for
for your business so what I would
suggest is to be prepared from the
beginning that such things like
modification of of users personal data
or sometimes just even removal of some
subsets of of the users from your model
is possible and it's one of those
scenarios so when the situation happens
in the real life you you have all the
things automated and prepared so it's
not not something that will break your
company operations for some weeks or
months so as I said automation is the
the key for that if you are software
developers you probably already are
familiar with the systems like
continuous integration and your shipping
process is automated maybe to just write
in one one line of command in in
terminal in order to go through each
step but as maybe as a data scientist or
more research person you you in the past
you did this steps manually and it won't
scale so easily so try to if you do if
you for example making project from the
scratch I think after each step you you
make I think okay can I just pack pack
it into this script or
other piece of code that can be easily
run by somebody else
can be connected with with other scripts
I wrote in the past so the whole process
of really running or data import is is
automated and as I said it's important
to make it early even if you are doing
some proof of concept from my experience
after showing successful proof of
concept of machine learning project or
even a regular software development
project to to my bus the first thing
that comes from him is okay if it works
just let's just put it on production as
soon as possible and so when you you are
doing proof of concept you may think
okay we will write it from the scratch
if it's successful or we will brainstorm
how to do it better but for your boss
it's not it can be a different
perspective so if at this step of
showing the results you already have
those automated pipelines ready it will
be easier to go with production okay and
the another thing is that sometimes it's
it's better to go start with simple
models so you probably knew everything
about deep neural networks and other
black box solutions but in case when
user kind will come to you and he'll
want answers for the the question why I
was refused of getting a credit or a
mortage or why I got this diagnosis in
yours
them or why system said that I'm healthy
and later I got sick and to answer those
questions about why you with we've
complicated models like like deep neural
networks you it's an it's is very it's
very hard to provide those answers and
so you should you should be sure of
what's the thing that you want to
optimize if its accuracy or its
interpretability and sometimes are made
in most cases it's better to make a
model that that behaves a little that
performs a little bit lower but you
actually can say what's happening under
the mask or you can minimize this black
box part of the the system ok and the
last the last part is about a more
ethical approach so what Judy Perez
tries to minimize is also the risk of
bias and so how how you how you check if
the output of your of your model of your
product is fair for all the users or how
you check if if it's not unfair in some
edge cases so the answer for that would
be to to provide some testing testing
data for example if you do project which
use personal information of patients be
sure that
it's don't it's not only trained for a
specific group of for example white male
patients but it's that the group is
diversified because and users are
diversified and and in solutions like
for example credit scoring be sure that
things like for example the zip code
it's not correlated with can sometimes
correlate with some factors like for
example race and be sure that those
correlation don't happen in your in your
system because sometimes even if you
remove things that you shouldn't analyze
some other data can lead to lead to that
so it's wise to sometimes sit and
brainstorm okay if if it's really if we
protect on those people okay and the
last advice which I saw especially in
when working with with business people
is to not ignore domain experts so I
know that and to and much learning
models could be really efficient but
it's it's still good to consult that the
possible outputs and and to learn more
about what what data is collected from
the the people who work with that so to
give you an example if you work on some
psych software and want to build lead
qualifications
system so you want to score your
customers of how big is the chance of
making a good deal with them I
I personally said that when I started
talking with sales people who work with
the clients directly they had some
intuitions and some informations for me
that showed me that okay that's those
are features that I should look on but
from the other side they also provide
some insight about okay but if if we use
this this data it's probably not so okay
to to make decisions based on for
example some employee information
because that from day perspective it's
not another data point it's something
that they can see that they don't want
to be used on them so they we shouldn't
build the system that uses this this
data points okay
that's all if you have some more
specific questions I like to thank you
very much you cash
[Applause]
very interesting which you always say of
course after a talk but but specifically
you know if you have any questions I
would have one but I'll let you first
ask questions anyone can't see any
hello thank you for the talk the
question I have is when you start
collecting data and not yet have a model
in place you don't know which data you
will need in order to fit the model
properly so there's a trade-off between
not collecting the data and collecting
the maximum data because you don't know
which one will be the appropriate ones
on how to fix this looking into the
future okay so from my experience I
would say that the first thing is if you
want to collect that if that data
contains personal information about the
users the first wise things to do to do
is to actually tell the user that you
will collect it and I'll try to also
communicate that it may be used later to
do some things that what you want to
build but you don't know yet what what's
required
so each data point another thing is you
probably when you collect that data you
probably have some end product in mind
so still I think that there are things
that you with common sense you think
that will not play the role and if they
are like some personal things you still
you would need to use the common sense
to provide you yourself answer okay I
think that I'm building some
recommendation system but that data
above health is not necessary yeah it's
it's hard so if you want to make
something innovative it's hard to know
if maybe maybe that data is good proxy
tool to give better results but then I
would go with like full transparency to
the to the users so I would say
okay there's something that can be built
that can help you with with this
information but you need to be aware
that I collect it and I will use it in
the future it's the best answer is not
try not to hide the things thank you so
a short question from me you touched
upon the topic of documentation now my
experience is that obviously the
documentation varies with regard to who
is going to be recipient of it do you
have any best practices in how you
structure that documentation in a way
which enables then more transparency in
explaining the model so I have
experience with two types of such
documentation the first one was was did
for healthcare certification audits and
it required a lot of diagrams and visual
explanations of how the system works so
and another one was what was a more
internal and it was more about how to
conduct the experiments and how to
present the results as well so your
question is is can you oh so you know
there is a different level of depth for
documentation when you do it and
obviously when you want to maintain the
maintain explain ability or transparency
of your model you probably need to
structure the commentation differently
too right yes so so I think that it's
important to have the template of the
documentation of the object the
beginning and for example for an
internal documentation we also had a
template of showing their results and
some restrictions or some suggestions of
how - for example if you provide so
visualization or charts what we also
tried to apply some like external best
practices of how to present that that
the visualizations so I would say that
mmm
it's like it varies from in each case
but if you have a team have a team you
should just talk at the beginning of
building about building that the
templates so later when for example
another person joins the team and his or
she is not used to writing the dogs it's
easier for them to write it properly and
Hugh minimized the amount of work to be
done because if you are as like me
developer dad
it's not his I'm not good at writing
long piece of text but if I have the
template that I need to only fill in for
example about the experiment which data
was used and I know that okay I need to
present the results in such way I need
to provide those those parameters it's
very easier thank you very much so again
thank you very much Mukesh and we're
gonna have a changeover now with Omar
joining us so three minutes and we start
another talk
thanks again
you